what is the biggest red flags you guys
see in girls
she doesn't offer to pay her share in
the first date i disagree with you on
that
i think it's a great red flag that's
fine
i don't think that's that big of a deal
she doesn't offer to pay on a first date
no because she's not entitled to my time
all my money yeah but sometimes guys
just offer to pay no no fight you for it
no i think it's good that i've got no
it's good that a guy pays but i'm saying
it's
the lack of gesture is a red flag the
lack of gesture yeah because it goes off
sometimes i just feel really awkward i'm
gonna be honest sometimes i'm like my
guy so let's say you see a girl yeah
yeah and you turn you asked her to come
on a date with you yep
you took her out of her own space i
didn't take her anywhere she chose to
come i hear that thank you she was
chilling like
she wasn't that that wasn't happening
like she loki wanted him to ask him
thank you she's not gonna she's not
gonna say yes if she doesn't want to
come yeah she wanted to come but she
wasn't gonna ask him so he asked her all
right what i'm saying is
is you're you see a girl that you like
yep and you asked her that can't take
you on a date
you then feel that you she should then
also pay no no i didn't say she should
pay i said she should she should offer
no no she should offer to pay her share
if i when i if i take girl if i actually
go out on a date
i'm always gonna pay
but i want her to offer to pay her share
that's what i was getting i was just
making sure that
that was the main thing that you'd
always want to pay because you took it
out yeah but you just want to see like
if she would help out too
it's a lot it's for me it's just showing
it's it's a sign of appreciation she's
like
you don't have to do this for me
but i appreciate when you do
because she there are things that she
will do that she doesn't have to do for
me but i'll appreciate like
if she
i know she cooks for me
it's like it's not i'm not like oh
because you're a woman you have to do
that so i'm like oh thanks baby
i was super thankful and i was like oh
that's so nice like thank you so much
you would still think i was like
entitled
uh
because most guys just grab it
no that's what i'm saying yeah saying
thank you okay like being being
appreciative okay i'm not gonna fight
you for it i won't no but i'd be like oh
no i don't mind if you spit this i don't
know it's okay okay great thanks but i
do
i'm not
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna lie to you i
do like you asked me no but it's just
it's just about it's just about it's
just about being polite it's just about
being boy that's how i say thank you
that's still polite yeah that's all
right that's all right
okay glad to know i wouldn't get i
wouldn't get sent packing
i don't say thank you but like if she
doesn't even say she doesn't offend she
doesn't even say thank you i i know the
vibe no way i'm taking you out again i
know i know the vibe you're talking
about i get it i know i'd say oh
my bad it's okay there's always this
happens sorry this happens i i think if
i think though if you if you start to
say that you think that um
women should pay half which by the way i
always think which is not what i'm
saying no no but i'm saying if you
expect a woman to at least offer even if
you say no
um i think then does that not imply that
you also talking back to the
expectations of what you want from a
woman does that then not just say you
don't just want a woman who's pretty and
in shape you know i want a woman who is
financially stable because no it's poor
i think yeah and polite but no but if a
woman wasn't financially stable she
would not offer because if you said yeah
all right and then she's like sure i've
got no money in my bank account but i
think it's the polite would you agree
like it's because you want her to be
polite
yeah i think i think if i'm being honest
i think part of it is maybe i think i'm
maybe a bit more uh sensitive to that
because the way i've been raised is to
always be grateful when think people do
things for you so i think for me that's
quite important we were talking about
this the other day i'm like i think it's
bad i prefer like just hanging out over
dates oh yeah you talk about that today
yeah yeah
that you would rather just like i
invited guys but it's not a good thing
i'm like i should like
coaching you absolutely not i know
because more cuz i'm lazy and so i'm
like
i'm like i gotta go downtown
i get put off if like say
i've met someone
online or in person and they're like oh
like without stop uh um that provocative
they just go oh so um where are you
taking me to
like it it's a trigger for me instantly
like as soon as that said i don't want
to take out no more because like you
kind of expect me to just take out and
then all of a sudden pay you like a
cinderella kind of thing if that makes
sense
so especially in an app oh my god that's
gonna keep the first date the first date
i'm not trying to go out to like dinner
because what if okay what if i match
with you on an app okay
and you start sending me weird stuff you
know what i mean like straight away like
or like didn't you go out with him would
you well no i wouldn't but like i meant
like when i get there oh i said sending
sorry wrong word wrong word but like
what if i get there and like it's weird
like then i how am i gonna leave before
i had dinner you know what i mean
you're like am i supposed to go hungry
yeah that's that's why we have ask for
angela in england have you seen if
you've ever been i was gonna say if
you've ever been in women's toilets you
probably haven't but um there's a they
always have to sing on the back saying
ask for angela so you can ask at the
back and you say oh is angela working
and they'll provide you a taxi back home
if you've got a date that's going south
really yeah
i've never known that yeah yeah yeah if
you've got
if you've got a date that's going south
and part of it is from a protection
point of view of if this person is
giving you vibes of like this person is
potentially going to kidnap me and i
could end up buried in a ditch somewhere
but also if it's free
i don't know see i don't think i think
if
[Laughter]
i think it's probably at the pubs
discretion but i would imagine that it's
not free if you were just like oh i'm
just really not having a great i'm just
you know what i'm not feeling i know but
i could be like could you take me in my
day
i'm just saying i'm just i'm asking for
angela i i grew up with a very cheap dad
okay
i love me a bargain
well i yeah
all right question for the ladies what's
uh what's a red flag
for you that you you see in the guy
first impressions
red flag
ah
um
if he tries to show me his mixtape
do people even have this yes i used to i
used to do i used to do rap reactions so
people used to oh really
no no um i'm like seriously but like
some rapper who's you've done that with
is watching this like what the [ __ ]
no have it in it
no no um it's a real red flag um
i would say like if they're talking
about their past relationships and like
everything is the girl's fault or like
the girls crazy
i'm like okay so either you like crazy
women okay
which isn't that's not good
i'm like then offensive why are you out
with me
or two or two like like you probably
cheat like because in my mind it's like
oh he's probably a cheater because
why are all these girls going crazy like
because i have brothers they date
and their girlfriends don't go crazy on
them because they're not they're not
cheaters i don't do that i have a
question you said something interesting
yeah you like
you should like well the second thing
is that he's probably a cheater because
he made them crazy
if it's a pattern one off that's one
thing but if it's a pattern you're the
common denominator but
but why would you
why would you say
that if they're all crazy
it's because of him why is that even an
option in your why because i would say
the same thing for a girl so you would
say if a girl was like to you like every
guy i've been with has been abusive to
me you'd be like well what the [ __ ] did
you do yes i swear to god yes yes
i mean i might say to her face but i'm
thinking it like what did you do like i
just wanna i just wanna clarify if you
go through life and you have the same
patterns in all of your relationships
like how can you not
i just i just want to clarify right
because this might get you some in some
hot water okay okay
you're saying that there's a possibility
that if a girl gets abused it's her own
fault
yeah because some girls some girls
attack the guys first no no yeah if she
gives you i know but so so if it's
either like there's either two issues
with her she's either she picks guys
that are abusers why are you picking men
that are it's the same thing i would say
the same way why are you picking men
that are abusers because and like i've
been in like a bad relationship before
where like i would say he was crazy it
was my own damn fault like
what was not every relationship but like
you know what i'm saying like i feel
like you should take accountability for
who you pick no i no i i agree with you
yeah but like you said that was the
first option right so the first option
you're like okay
clearly he's choosing wrong yeah then he
said the second option you're like oh
he's triggered them to behave this way
yeah and you think that's a thing yes i
think league
yeah like if a guy
can trigger if a guy if a guy's cheated
on every single girl that he's been like
like of course they're gonna act crazy
and i do i think like i think the girl
should probably just leave but as a
woman like we kind of know that like
like what are you doing i